elle s'entend aussi bien avec le rappeur
Akhenaton qu'avec le couple Macron mon
invité est à l'aise partout avec tout le
monde et c'est peut-être cela qui a fini
par l'amener à la politique
[Musique]
bonjour Sabrina Gressy roubache bonjour
alors il y a un meeting dont tout le
monde se souvient dans la campagne
présidentielle d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017
c'est celui de la Porte de Versailles on
s'en souvient pourquoi
parce que c'est le fameux meeting de
parce que c'est notre projet alors je me
suis dit qu'Emmanuel Macron avait dû
avoir un sacré bon chauffeur de salle ce
jeudi on se met dans cet état là et
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait et ben j'ai
regardé le tout début
[Musique]
bonjour donc voilà je m'appelle Sabrina
roubache je suis né dans l'un des
arrondissements les plus pauvres les
plus pauvres d'Europe moi je viens de
cette zone très compliquée et où
l'éducation m'a aidé c'est vrai sans
éducation on ne peut pas y arriver alors
c'est votre témoignage à vous vous
prenez la parole en ouverture de ce
meeting à l'époque vous étiez très
éloigné de la politique moi ce que vous
êtes retrouvé là micro en main devant
des milliers de personnes
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est l'histoire en fait d'une rencontre
assez improbable en réalité ou Emmanuel
Macron donc vient lancer sa campagne à
Marseille et il demande à ses équipes de
l'organiser un dîner c'est ça le départ
à Marseille avec le monde
socio-économique et plutôt des noms
politiques donc plutôt des gens des
chefs d'entreprise mais aussi des
associatifs donc je me retrouve à table
dans un restaurant assez
en vue de Marseille et c'est Brigitte
Macron qui m'installe à côté d'elle et
moi à l'époque je venais de rencontrer
celui qui deviendra mon futur mari
Jean-Philippe et je vais la voir en lui
disant brigitte c'est super adorable tu
m'as mis à côté de toi et je l'ai
tutoyer tout de suite hein
j'aimerais juste être à côté en fait de
Jean-Philippe est-ce que tu peux juste
me mettre à côté de toi et puis tu mets
quelqu'un d'autre à ta place toi tu vas
rester ici et ces gens Philippe qu'on va
déplacer et ça c'est le début d'une
rencontre très marquante mais ça ça
s'est passé donc moins d'un mois
et Emmanuel Macron moi ce qui
m'intéressait comment enfin pourquoi il
vous a choisi vous pour ouvrir votre
meeting alors que vous connaissez à
peine c'est Brigitte qui m'appelle ils
sont tous les deux et elle me dit
écoutez pas du tout obligé d'accepter et
il voudrait en fait que tu ouvres son
plus gros à vous et alors sincèrement je
pense que c'est à eux qu'il faut poser
la question et à lui notamment et si moi
j'ai pas encore en réalité j'ai pas la
réponse parce que quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissez pas que vous connaissez à
peine avec qui bien sûr après on a
échangé on s'est échangé tout de suite
des numéros mais je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas alors est-ce que c'est c'est ça
lui aussi est assez instinctif et assez
moi c'est en tout cas c'est l'un des
points communs que j'avais cru c'est
pour ça que je j'ai tout de suite
accroché que vous étiez la bonne
personne la bonne personne au bon moment
qui était capable de le faire parce que
parler devant 15000 personnes comme vous
n'avez jamais pris la parole devant qui
que ce soit voilà
vous êtes devenus avec les Macron on l'a
compris en l'espace d'une soirée quand
on vous connaît un peu on a l'impression
que bah c'est quelque chose de naturel
chez vous que vous êtes capable de
devenir ami avec n'importe qui de
n'importe quel milieu alors vous diriez
que c'est un don alors c'est pas avec
n'importe qui au contraire moi je suis
assez j'aime pas j'aime j'aime pas je
suis assez comme un petit animal c'est
j'ai du mal quand même c'est pour ça que
la politique c'est compliqué pour moi
parce que je vois bien le nombre de
compositions qu'il faut faire le nombre
de l'abnégation que ça demande en
réalité donc non je suis par contre
j'aime les gens non moi ce la chose qui
est vrai j'aime les gens et je me
soutiens assez peu de la couleur
politique mais depuis toujours je pense
pas que les étiquettes fassent les
hommes sans quoi ça serait trop facile
alors Emmanuel Macron et Marseille c'est
une histoire d'amour on sait qu'Emmanuel
Macron est un grand fan de l'OM et
l'Olympique de Marseille mais ça va
au-delà il a envie de faire de Marseille
peu le laboratoire de sa politique et
vous tenez un rôle dans ce dispositif on
vous surnomme souvent la vigie
Marseillaise des Macron est-ce que vous
vous retrouvez dans cette expression ah
oui je me retrouve parce que j'ai pas
attendu d'être élu pour parler et
travailler sur Marseille avec lui
notamment
il aime Marseille c'est une sincérité
c'est sincère c'est à dire quand il
explique à ses simplement ce qui le
relie à Marseille et en réalité il est
marseillais dans le tempérament à
Marseille il se sent bien et il a quand
même cette foule ce côté rebelle vigie
marseillaise oui vous vous êtes là pour
l'informer un peu de ce qui se passe à
Marseille oui et lui donner le vrai son
de la rue en fait c'est quoi qui est
intéressant c'est peut-être une
déformation professionnelle moi je ne
sais pas mentir je ne sais pas travestir
et il sait que tous les mots qui sortent
de ma bouche et tous les mots qui sont
écrits ne sont que sincérité assez cash
je reconnais que je suis assez direct
quand je pense quelque chose je le dis
et il sait que j'ai aussi le sens de la
confidentialité je le sens du secret et
il y a des choses qu'on se dit et que je
dirais jamais jusqu'à ma mort ça partira
avec moi et la réalité sur la vigie on
est une vigie quand on est capable de
donner l'alerte de donner l'alerte mais
aussi de dire ce qui va bien c'est à
dire la vigie dans tout dans tous les
sens du mot alors il y a vous avez un
autre qualité si on peut dire c'est que
vous êtes capable de faciliter des
rencontres d'ouvrir des portes de
provoquer des choses un peu inattendues
inespérées et c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'il y a Macron vous a confié une
mission assez étonnante et vous a
demandé en 2020 de travailler au
rapprochement de la majorité
présidentielle et la droite Marseillaise
et Renault Muselier en particulier alors
que vous êtes plutôt de gauche vous
étiez novice en politique à l'époque et
vous êtes parvenu avec une vraie comment
vous avez fait alors vous savez quoi là
j'ai déployé justement j'ai évité de
faire j'ai pas fait de politique je suis
allé voir un homme Muselier je l'écris
dans mon livre assez simplement en lui
disant il y a un danger ARN parce que la
réalité vous savez c'est pas parce qu'on
salue pas les députés RN à la buvette
qu'on combat leurs idées moi je les
salue à la buvette mais je combats leurs
idées et la réalité c'est que nous à
Marseille on est vraiment confronté à
une vague RN très forte et en région sud
encore plus faut jamais oublier qu'on
est l'une des régions les plus exposées
et quand à le convaincre de parler avec
le coeur lui c'est un politique parce
que la première réponse qu'il me dit
c'est il me dit tu sais que la politique
c'est sérieux et je sais que c'est
d'autant plus sérieux que vous n'étiez
pas non c'est sous-entendu là on fait de
la politique et je lui ai répondu je
sais mais je viens te voir non pas avec
une âme de politique parce que je suis
pas une politique je viens te voir parce
qu'il y a un enjeu pour nous tuer je
suis marseillaise on se connaît un peu
le président de la République a compris
l'enjeu quand même sur la vague RN et
c'est le moment où jamais de travailler
ensemble alors quand on voit votre
personnalité on se dit que c'est sans
doute pas un hasard si votre vie c'est
un peu construite autour de quelques
rencontres il y a eu la rencontre avec
les Macron et puis une autre rencontre
avant bien avant celle d'Akhenaton
figure emblématique du groupe IAM est-ce
que vous diriez que cette rencontre elle
est un peu changé le cours de votre vie
oui oui clairement alors oui changer le
cours de ma vie surtout le changer le
cours de ma de ma carrière je l'ai connu
assez fun même voilà et je venais donc
moi je suis né à Félix Piat et dans ce
quartier Félix Piat les gens donc les
tous les personnages de comme un aimant
sont des amis à lui de faire comme un
aimant le premier long-métrage qu'on
réalisé par et par Kamel salé qui est un
jeune aussi de félicites avec qui on a
grandi et ça en fait au départ moi
j'étais plutôt partie sur une carrière
de ou d'assistante sociale ou de ou
d'avocats ou de magistrates et la preuve
en première année de droit et vous
embarque sur la les clips d'abord et moi
petit à petit
linéaire dans la production j'ai démarré
stagiaire de prod et je finis pro du
Christ mais j'ai mis 25 ans à faire ça
tout le monde pense que parce que
maintenant on parle un peu plus de moins
et que je fais des choses plus visibles
non moi c'est les échelons le premier
échelon il est là avec Akhenaton c'est
celui avec qui je me retrouvais le plus
mais jusqu'à même si on n'est pas
d'accord même si on n'est pas d'accord
sur tout vous êtes lancés dans la
production de films de série de
documentaires et puis un jour Netflix
s'est tourné vers vous pour produire sa
première grosse série française
Marseille avec Gérard Depardieu Benoît
Magimel et là et ben une fois de plus
votre travail a consisté un peu à ouvrir
des portes à facilité des rencontres le
créateur de la série qui est mon témoin
de mariage
à prendre le pouls de la ville ne
comprenait pas la ville on ne pouvait
pas il ne pouvait pas tourner à
Marseille et Pascal breton qui est lui
le producteur l'a compris tout de suite
vous dites que ce travail que vous avez
fait sur Netflix Marseille tout ça ça
sert de déclic pour vous pour prendre un
peu conscience que vous étiez capable de
convaincre n'importe qui ça veut dire
que c'est le déclic aussi quelque part
de d'une prise de de confiance en vous
pour vous lancer en politique
la confiance en soi c'est certain mais
surtout la conscience de ce qu'il y
avait à faire des engagements que je
pouvais prendre alors vous raconter
votre parcours personnel dans un livre
qui s'appelle moi la France je la kiffe
donc c'est une enfance heureuse dans une
famille nombreuse installée dans un
quartier pauvre de Marseille vos parents
sont nés en Algérie vous avez grandi mon
père Provence d'accord et vous dites
vous avez grandi dans une double culture
et vous dites que pour vous il y a pas
d'ambiguïté votre pays c'est la France
vous kiffez la France comme vous dites
pourquoi est-ce que vous ressentez ce
besoin de l'affirmer comme ça parce que
malheureusement
c'est très franco-français ça veut le
voir moi qui est beaucoup voyagé on vous
ramène souvent à vos origines ethniques
c'est très bizarre c'est très curieux et
vos origines sociales et c'est souvent
d'où tu viens c'est quoi ta religion et
c'est pour ça que je me suis amusé à
écrire un chapitre sur le couscous et la
bouillabaisse en disant les idées
préconçues qui consiste à dire mais
parce que en fait d'origine maghrébine
tu vas plus aimer pas du tout c'est
c'était une province c'était une manière
aussi assez provocante de dire les
choses et on nous ramène souvent ça le
président de la République pareil il a
dit souvent on nous ramène souvent à nos
origines et c'est terrible parce qu'en
fait on est bien sûr ça englobe notre
personnalité ça nous construit mais moi
je suis française enfin pour moi il y a
pas de sujet en fait ce n'est pas de
sujet vous aimez la France mais alors
une France ouverte une France tolérante
plurielle et le 21 avril 2002 quand
Jean-Marie Le Pen se qualifie pour ce
concours de la présidentielle ça vous
met dans une colère noire vous décidez
quitter la France et vous allez vivre au
Maroc pendant plusieurs années est-ce
que vous prendriez la même décision
aujourd'hui maintenant que vous êtes
député est-ce que que ce serait pas un
peu quitter le navire en pleine tempête
c'est pas parce que je suis député c'est
parce que j'ai vieilli on prend pas
pareil à 25 ans qu'à 46 ans c'est une
évidence évidemment je reprendrai pas du
tout la même décision et ça je me suis
questionné on quitte pas on quitte pas
le navire c'est exactement ce que je me
suis dit quand je suis revenue je me
suis rendu compte en réalité qu'on
vivait dans le plus beau pays du monde
quand je suis allé voir ailleurs et je
me rends compte quand même aussi qu'on
rend assez mal en réalité à la France
tout ce qu'elle donne et quel que soit
l'origine on passe à notre quiz je vous
explique le principe je vais commencer à
prononcer une phrase et ça va être à
vous de la compléter ok c'est bon on y
va on y va dans l'hémicycle le meilleur
comédien c'est le meilleur comédien
c'est vous la productrice vous avez un
regard là dessus c'est vous non
on a le droit de dire ce qu'on veut
non je sais pas s'il y a des connards le
meilleur comédien il y en a trop en fait
j'ai du mal à choisir mais
je non après ça ça mettrait quand même
des collègues dans l'embarras mais je
dirais c'est moi c'est moi parce qu'en
réalité je oui je suis la productrice
mais quand vous êtes dans la semaine
juste une une citation de Nassim Nicolas
Taleb qui dit il vaut mieux avoir la
conscience de l'ignorance que la
certitude du savoir
plus je fais de la politique plus je me
dis que c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
au point de vous dire que un seul mandat
pas deux j'arrive à comprendre en
réalité j'arrive à comprendre en réalité
la désaffection des gens pour la
politique donc un seul mandat a priori
ouais moi j'avais dit j'ai commencé avec
Emmanuel Macron et j'en aurai fini avec
lui très probablement j'ai beau être
marseillaise j'avoue qu'à Paris
c'est une très belle ville quand même
vous le dites c'est une magnifique ville
allez on va terminer l'émission en
musique est-ce que vous reconnaissez
cette chanson j'imagine que oui
des chansons les plus connues du groupe
IAM on allait tourner au Frioul enfin on
a tourné de partout c'était magnifique
est-ce que votre histoire aurait pu
ressembler à celle de ce gamin des cités
qui étaient évoqué dans cette chanson
evidemment si j'avais pas eu les parents
que j'ai eu vous devez votre parcours à
vos parents moi ma mère ma grand-mère ma
grand-mère dont on a pas pris
l'importance qu'ils accordaient à
l'éducation à l'éducation et à la à
l'appareil à la conscience de ce qu'on
était dans le monde de non pas que
recevoir mes données mes données on
oublie beaucoup voilà le mot de la fin
Merci à VOUS Sabrina agressive et moi
merci beaucoup
pourquoi ça pue